it's only februari and I may have
discovered one of the worst films of
2013 already identity thief sucks I
almost walked out of this movie that's
really the only way to describe this
film it's too long it's annoying you
won't laugh you might chuckle you
probably won't and all the characters
are [ __ ] [ __ ] that are just
[ __ ] all over the screen it has a
great premise but it does not take
advantage of his potential half the
jokes are Jason Bateman being dead pan
and having a girl's name and the other
half are Melissa McCarthy being fat and
obnoxious and yes they're both [ __ ]
it's like a little fat kid wrote this
movie farted on the screenplay and said
hey Universal Pictures might want to
produce this big pile of [ __ ] I mean
there's not much to say it's a comedy is
it funny no it dramatically overstays
its welcome and it's a surprise than
with all the supporting roles all the
cameos and the film's director that this
film makes you want to die it's one big
pile of roadkill no pun intended because
it's a roadtrip movie I guess there's a
pun intended get it all in all I gotta
say identity thief sucks the biggest
fattest balls and got it wrong
you
you